[Music]
kate middleton attends wimbledon
and no surprise here looks chic and
regal as ever
very excited the 39 year old mom of
three stepped out on friday to enjoy the
annual tennis tournament
she serves as the royal patron of the
all england lawn tennis and croquet club
which hosts the annual event check out
kate's exquisite ensemble
a white blouse navy blue blazer polka
dot skirt
white purse and white heels she was
photographed entering the event with her
mask
on but once seated she removed it
clearly kate was having a ball
courtside laughing smiling and cheering
as the athletes competed very friendly
so yeah i couldn't have it couldn't have
gone easier really for me
attending wimbledon this year was
seemingly extra special for kate
because last year the tournament was
cancelled due to the coronavirus
pandemic
according to the duke and duchess of
cambridge's official instagram account
quote it's amazing to see fans and
players back inside
these iconic grounds they even shared a
quote
unbiased prediction to win andy murray
and emma radukenu and even though the
tournament was forced to take a year off
kate is proud that the aeltc has
continued to do incredible work
giving back to the local community
through wingfield kitchen
providing 200 hot meals a day for a year
to those in need
no one would ever know and so we use
quick faster 1.2 million
there's the duchess lending a hand in
the kitchen piping cream and preparing a
dessert with strawberries
but it doesn't end there kate also got a
tour
of the wimbledon museum she checked out
multiple exhibits and even got a
close-up look at the massive men's
singles champion trophy
it's been quite a sporty week for the
duchess on tuesday she was joined by her
husband prince william and their eldest
child
seven-year-old prince george as they
attended a soccer match at wembley
stadium
the young royal looked so excited to
watch england defeat germany
and secure its place in the
quarterfinals also at the event the
famous family was photographed catching
up with former soccer pro
david beckham it's quite exciting
actually and while kate made appearances
at both athletic events
she was noticeably not in attendance at
the unveiling of the statue of her late
mother-in-law princess diana
in the sunken garden at kensington
palace we
had heard speculation and rumors that
possibly the duchess of cambridge
might have attended but in fact with
this becoming a much more
scaled back engagement than what it was
originally meant to be with
around 100 guests it felt like a fitting
and suitable
crowd of people william and his younger
brother prince harry revealed the statue
together in a private ceremony that
included
several members of diana's family the
spencers
given covid and the restrictions in
place it felt right that it was
william and harry with the spencer side
of the family